mr. Bush did die late last night at his
home in Houston Texas Omar Villafranca
is in Houston near st. Martin's
Episcopal Episcopal Church where the
funeral for the former president will be
held tomorrow
good morning Dana the president actually
lived just a few blocks from where we're
standing but all eyes are on st.
Martin's Episcopal Church behind me
that's where we're expecting services to
be held early next week it's also the
same church where his wife the former
first lady barbara Bush had her services
when she died earlier this year
now as this news started to spread we
are seeing reaction from one of the most
exclusive clubs in the world people who
call themselves the most powerful person
in the world the President of the United
States in fact Bill Clinton who of
course ran against George HW Bush in the
92 presidential election and beat him
and later formed a close friendship with
him issued a statement reading in part
few Americans have been or ever will be
able to match President Bush's record of
service to the United States he never
stopped serving I saw it up close
working with him on tsunami relief in
Asia and here at home after Hurricane
Katrina
I am proudly profoundly grateful for
every minute I spent with President Bush
and will always hold our friendships as
one of my life's greatest gifts Barack
Obama said America has lost a patriot
and a humble servant while our hearts
are heavy today
they are also filled with gratitude and
George W Bush the 43rd President of the
United States said George HW Bush was a
man of the highest character and the
best dad a son or daughter could ask for
we also wanted to show you this tweet
it's from Jim McGrath who's the
president's longtime spokesperson and
it's believed to be the last time mr.
Bush was seen in public he was joined by
his Secretary of State James Baker and
his service dog Sully and President Bush
was casting a vote in last month's
election and for the people here in the
Houston area and in South Central Texas
in this part of Texas the Bush family
was a staple they would see him at
Astros games they would see him at
Houston Texans games he'd go an hour and
a half away to College Station at Texas
A&M for football games where his
Presidential Library is so a lot of
Texans and people
across the nation who went to bed last
night are waking up to some very sad
news
Anthony giant in the community they're
Omar Villafranca and Houston thanks so
much Omar